"Ці дні", "ті самі дні", "гості приїхали", "жіночі дні", "справи почалися", "критичні дні", "червоні дні календаря"… Місячні!
Так, давайте поговоримо про... менструацію!
Чому ми використовуємо стільки евфемізмів для того, що відбувається щомісяця?
Чомусь ця тема - все ще табу, ми не любимо згадувати це слово без якоїсь на те причини!
Отже, почнімо з самого початку... Що таке менструація?
Менструація - це частина циклу жіночого організму, який триває в середньому 28 днів.
Але також нормально, якщо він триває від 21 до 35 днів. Цикл починається з першого дня місячних.
Під час менструального циклу яйцеклітина дозріває всередині свого роду оболонки, званої фолікулом, в одному з двох яєчників.
Потім вона потрапляє в маткову трубу і починає свій шлях у напрямку матки.
Якщо на шляху зустрічаються сперматозоїди, яйцеклітина може бути запліднена.
У той же час матка готується до можливої ​​вагітності: слизова оболонка потовщується, потенційно готуючись прийняти запліднену яйцеклітину.
Якщо яйцеклітина не вступає в контакт зі сперматозоїдами, то слизовий секрет залоз шийки матки стає непотрібним.
І організм природним чином видаляє його - разом з яйцеклітиною.
Це і є щомісячна кровотеча. За обсягом, напевно, менше, ніж ви думаєте - у середньому всього 50-65 мілілітрів.
Можливо, ви дивуєтеся, чому менструальна кров не зовсім схожа на кров з рани, коли, наприклад, ви порізали палець.
Причина в тому, що менструальна кров також містить деяку кількість рідини з піхви і особливі тканини,
які з'являються в матці, коли організм готується до можливої ​​вагітності.
Але якщо ви не вагітні, то організм вирішує усього цього позбутися.
Це все одно що... знімати зимовий одяг, коли приходить літо.
Або... вимикати світло, коли на вулиці розвиднюється...
Або відкрити завісу перед початком нового шоу. Ну, ви розумієте, про що я.
Менструація не є чимось брудним або токсичним! Це просто суміш крові, клітин і слизової рідини, яких наш організм більше не потребує.
І це цілком природний процес. Цього не треба соромитися!
Це не повинно викликати огиду. Якщо ви погано себе почуваєте під час менструації, нічого страшного. Просто відпочиньте.
Але якщо ви почуваєте себе добре, немає причин, через які менструація заважає вам що-небудь робити.
Я маю на увазі, що ви можете нормально вчитися, ходити магазинами, займатися спортом, працювати... і навіть займатися сексом.
Звісно, ви можете займатися сексом під час менструації! Деяким жінкам у ці дні секс приносить навіть більше задоволення.
Але ви все одно можете завагітніти, тому що нова яйцеклітина вже може бути в дорозі.
Є ще одна важлива річ про менструацію - вона може бути доволі болісною!
Біль під час менструації і перед настанням місячних справді існує! Вам це не здається. І це абсолютно нормально.
Матка скорочується, я маю на увазі, що вона намагається виштовхнути те, що їй більше не потрібно. Так що в цьому немає нічого ганебного.
Звичайно, у вашому тілі відбувається набагато більше процесів... Одні тільки гормони чого варті!
Ці чотири види гормонів найсильніше впливають на менструальний цикл:
естроген, прогестерон, лютеїнізуючий гормон і фолікулостимулюючий гормон.
Безпосередньо перед овуляцією - це коли яйцеклітина виходить з яєчника, щоб вирушити в дорогу до матки - кількість естрогену в жіночому тілі сягає піку.
Естроген змушує тканину матки рости. Не зовсім зрозуміло, як естроген впливає на нашу психіку. Але нам здається, що ми сповнені енергії.
Після виходу яйцеклітини підвищується рівень прогестерону. Прогестерон дозволяє матці підготуватися до можливої ​​імплантації ембріона.
Він протидіє швидкому росту тканин під впливом естрогену, стримуючи процес і запобігаючи небажаному росту і раку.
Лютеїнізуючий гормон призводить до овуляції, яйцеклітина повинна покинути яєчник.
І останній, але не менш важливий - фолікулостимулюючий гормон. Він замикає цикл. Або запускає його - залежно як подивитися.
Тому що змушує нову яйцеклітину дозрівати в яєчниках.
І це він змушує організм виробити якусь кількість естрогену, який потім дозволяє тканинам матки рости.
Звісно, всі ці гормони можуть сильно впливати на нашу психіку.
Ви також можете відчувати сильні емоційні перепади - одні жінки стають трохи тривожнішими, інші - сумнішими.
Це може бути частиною передменструального синдрому.
Причини ПМС не зовсім зрозумілі. Але гормони безумовно відіграють у цьому роль.
Фізичними симптомами можуть бути: хворобливі відчуття в грудях, висипання прищів, втома...
А психологічними - занепокоєння, перепади настрою...
Але, дівчата, не дозволяйте нікому говорити вам, що ви поводите себе так тільки через менструацію!
Так, ці зміни відбуваються через гормональні зміни.
Але не ігноруйте їх, це нормально, тільки проявляється все трохи сильніше, ніж зазвичай.
Отже, наступного разу, коли у вас будуть місячні, замість того, щоб обурюватися, прийміть це як є
і скажіть собі: "Це моє тіло, і воно робить свою справу. Все гаразд".
Між іншим, менструація може стати причиною підвищеного газоутворення!
І якщо у вас пришвидшилося травлення, це теж нормально! З багатьма жінками так буває!
Це тому що гормони впливають на ваш організм і можуть потрапити в кишечник, який знаходиться поруч...
Але це все природно. Тож, якщо вас непокоять гази під час менструації, ви не самотні!